have you heard from Rebecca no do you
think she's upset that you wrote about
you and Rebecca I mean I thought you
were pretty respectful it gave me a
chance to tell the truth you know
anything less than the truth is
paralysis that's what I realized writing
this book I was like I have to be honest
I set out to write a hero story I did
this you know and that was like what the
[__] am I doing and it was a Do or Die
moment I actually said I I can't do this
take your money back I'm done but then I
decided to just dig in the Rebecca thing
I do want to address that because you
know of these headlines the last few
days week um you know John stavos hated
Rebecca and John stos called her the
devil none of that the way you know they
pull it out differently I never I didn't
hate it Rebecca I hated her after we
split up and I blamed her but after
writing this book I realized it was just
as much my fault and that's what I
wanted to get across about her that's it
when you say it was your fault what do
you think you did look I felt that I
became emasculated you became
emasculated because her acting career
was starting to take off she was taking
off and I just I wasn't paying attention
to mine and you know it wasn't her fault
I mean you know you just get wrapped up
in these things and I was H I said you
know what I've had enough Fame I'm okay
let's let's put the spotlight on her and
and I loved watching it I think that she
outgrew me and again like my my my naive
a you know I gave I used to give 50 60%
in anything and I thought well that my
50% is better than you know 99% of the
people out there I don't have to give it
all but I just you know I didn't work at
anything I didn't work as hard as I
should at anything you know acting do
you think you could have saved that
marriage no I think no I don't think so
I think she was over he was doomed that
was it at that point it was when you go
through Hollywood it hardly ever Works
something happens between people where
either they get jealous of one another
one gets more successful there's
landmines all over the place yeah there
are landmines but you don't first of all
she was just she was a model and she was
very successful and you don't think
about like oh we shouldn't get together
we're both Attractive people and we're
going to you know we're not going to
make it well I thought look my thing was
like and part of it the Heartbreak there
was that I was going to we were going to
have a family together we always talked
about kids and then when that talk
started to stop I was like oh [__] man
but again I'm here to say that you know
and I was so angry at her for so long as
you know and I'm just so happy to not be
angry I'm happy for her and I hope they
hear this the truth is I wish them the
best before I wrote this book I had a
lot of regrets after after writing it I
I just spilled it all and I realized
everything was there for a reason I you
know this DUI which I [__] hated but
you know it straightened me up and then
Caitlyn came around and I have a
beautiful son now and if if I didn't go
through what I did with Rebecca I I
wouldn't have been with Caitlyn I
wouldn't know how to
be